das Ende der AKW der Spiegel hat sie
genannt ich habe es eben zitiert den
Vater des deutschen Atomausstiegs aber
das Thema ist irgendwie noch nicht durch
es kommt Markus Söder um die Ecke und
sagt das sollten doch eigentlich die
Bundesländer auf eigene Faust weiter
betreiben können hatte haben sie haben
sich Verständnis dafür nein es ist
damals entschieden worden im Artikel 73
Ziffer 14 des Grundgesetzes dass der
Betrieb von Atomkraftwerken Bundessache
ist und dass die Länder das nur im
Auftrag des Bundes machen das hatte eine
Ursache weil es sich nämlich nicht um
harmloses Material handelt hier geht es
darum dass es eine Verantwortung für die
Gefahren von Proliferation also die
Weiterverbreitung von Technologie gibt
und deswegen ist das die
Verfassungsgrundlage
das einzige was ich an Söder empfehlen
würde wäre in der Tat ein Zusatz zur
bayerischen Verfassung da würde jetzt
mal den Weg gehen über die man reden
könnte das bayerische Atommüll
ausschließlich in Bayern gelagert werden
dürfe
nur mal einen Vorschlag gemacht wenn der
länderkompetenzen haben will und wenn
wir da schon wenn wir da schon Endlager
haben können wir den anderen Kram da
auch hinschicken über wie viel Müll
reden wir da eigentlich immer wir reden
jetzt über eine definierte Menge Müll
das ist wie viel ist das
hunderte Tonnen Atome lauen da draußen
unterschiedlich wir haben ein
legalisiertes Endlager das ist das
Schacht Konrad anstatt Konrad kommen die
schwach und mittelaktiven Stoffe rein
ähm in Salzgitter also die Niedersachsen
wissen wo es ist sie haben daneben noch
in der Asse bei Wolfenbüttel einen Leck
gelaufenes Lager da holen der Bund
gerade alle diesen Müll raus viel Müll
übrigens auch aus Bayern der da
angefallen ist und dann gibt es den
Versuch in einem sehr aufwendigen
Prozess ein Endlager für hochaktiven
radioaktiven Abfall zu finden das ist
wohl der gefährlichste Müll den die Welt
zu bieten hat dieser Prozess startet
oder ist gestartet und der hat natürlich
zur Voraussetzung dass Sie wissen müssen
wie viel Atommüll eingelagert werden
muss und dafür hat die Frage der
Begrenzung der Laufzeit auch in dem
Beschluss die damals die Kommission
unter einem CDU Menschen nämlich Klaus
töffer mit Zustimmung des
Bundesverbandes der deutschen Industrie
und der IG BCE gesprochen hat eine
wesentliche Rolle gespielt es ist ihr
Thema ich merke dass sie sind und wie
sie genüsslich sie zahlen sie zahlen
rezitiert trotzdem noch mal die Frage an
Cordula tut von der Wirtschaftswoche was
mit Blick auch auf deutsche Strompreise
ein Fehler diese drei akadem jetzt
abzuschalten
die drei AKW die Waren im streckbetrieb
die haben jetzt nicht mehr so viel Strom
beigetragen 5% waren es glaube ich
zuletzt im Vergleich zu früher ungefähr
zehn Prozent am Strommix
es ist aber was tatsächlich den Preis
angeht hätten wenn wir ein
pragmatischeres ausgewählt hätten und
die Laufzeiten noch etwas vielleicht
gestreckt hätten und anders umgegangen
wären hätten wir zwei Punkte besser
machen können wir hätten bei den Preisen
etwas Linderung schaffen können bei den
Privatpersonen ist es einfach so dass
die jetzt ärmer werden weil wir ein
neues normal haben bis die Erneuerbaren
tatsächlich das alles übernehmen haben
wir unvergleichlich hohe Strompreise in
Deutschland und das macht auch den
Unternehmen zu schaffen und das macht
sich bei der Industrie auch dauerhaft
womöglich mit Abwanderung bemerkbar
Grundstoffindustrie chemische Industrie
andere energieintensive Industrie dass
sie einfach sagen mit den Strompreisen
wollen wir können nicht mehr hier
bleiben und da hätten die aka wenige
gewisse Milderung bringen können und wir
haben jetzt auch noch ein extra Punkt
das ist jetzt jenseits der Preise
was machen wir sagen wir sind die Besten
in der Energiewende wir steigen auch aus
der Atomkraft aus aber wir feiern jetzt
wieder richtig Kohlekraftwerke Alter 2%
mehr Kohle und das ist natürlich jetzt
doppelte Sicht dumm weil wir jetzt
klimaschädlich unterwegs sind und weil
wir uns auch mit den anderen EU Nachbarn
irgendwie ist nicht besonders freundlich
einrichten weil für jeden für jede Tonne
CO2 die aus einem Kohle Schlot rauskommt
müssen wir uns Zertifikate kaufen die
werden dadurch teurer weil wir im großen
Maßstab auf diesem Markt jetzt Nachfrage
haben und damit sie auch Karte in Europa
weder was Klimaschutz angeht noch was
unbedingt der Freundlichkeit gegenüber
den Nachbarn angeht die Zertifikate
haben sie doch angeführt oder habe ich
das deswegen bin ich auch ganz ehrlich
wenn wir jetzt heute haben wir
zwei imitieren imitieren weil wir
Kohlekraftwerke hochgefahren haben unter
anderem übrigens um den Ausfall von
Atomkraftwerken in Frankreich zu
kompensieren so ändert sich an der Klima
Bilanz Strompreis überhaupt nichts weil
die Menge der Zeit die imitiert werden
darf ist gedeckelt das heißt was wir
jetzt mehr machen müssen wir früher
einsparen das heißt wir sorgen dafür
dass diese Kraftwerke früher von Netz
gehen würde man die Atomkraftwerke
länger laufen lassen könnten auch die
Kohlekraftwerke länger laufen bliebe die
Menge CO2 aber auch gleich also insofern
das Argument taucht überhaupt nichts was
die Preise angeht da gibt es sehr
unterschiedliche Berechnungen ich will
nur eines an dieser Stelle sagen weil
jetzt auch immer so ein Bild gesagt wer
soll das eigentlich ersetzen wenn es nur
um die Dimension ginge die die Atomkraft
je in Deutschland geliefert hat die zu
ersetzen dann hätten wir 2012 aus der
tumcraft aussteigen können weil zu
diesem Zeitpunkt war der Anteil der
Erneuerbaren an der Stromerzeugung so
hoch wie der Anteil der Atomkraft in
ihren besten Zeiten gewesen sind
inzwischen ist der Anteil doppelt so
hoch das heißt wir haben doppelt über
kompensiert und damit Räume geschaffen
beispielsweise also auch Kraftwerke wie
haben
Kohlekraftwerk was gerade glaube ich
sieben Jahre gelaufen müssen Moorburg
was fünf Jahre gelaufen ist vorzeitig
wieder vom Netz zu nehmen insofern das
eigentliche was hilft ist der Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien übrigens ein
Vorteil haben ein Windrad im verursacht
nur 10% der CO2-Emission eines
Atomkraftwerks aber schon eine gewisse
Doppelmoral also weil man Moral ich habe
ihn Zahlen vorgetragen im Reinigungs zu
tun
trotzdem machen insgesamt haben wir eben
nur diese Menge an co2-artikelkarten das
stimmt aber wir in Deutschland nehmen
uns jetzt gerade raus wir fahren die
Kohlekraft hoch und machen für alle in
dem Moment in den Jahren jetzt sind die
die
zum Teil aus europäischer Solidarität
weil wir die Franzosen nicht hängen
lassen und wir tun es um den Preis und
auch mal über Preise zu reden um den
Preis das auch im letzten Viertel Jahr
Windparks unter anderem in
Schleswig-Holstein
abgeschaltet werden mussten und wir sie
bezahlen mussten weil wir diese
Grundlastkraftwerke wie Atom und
Kohlekraftwerke nicht flexibel fahren
können das ist das ist etwas wir hatten
das kann man so nicht sagen zu viel wir
haben nord-süd-probleme in Deutschland
weil wir zu wenig Leitungen haben wir
haben einen leitungsproblem im Rest
Europas nur im Ergebnis war es so dass
wir ihm Geld dafür bezahlt haben CO2
freien Strom nicht zu produzieren
mit der Atomkraft das ist natürlich
insofern auch ein bisschen
widersprüchlich weil wir natürlich dann
doch in guten und in normalen Zeiten
stark drauf bauen eben auch Strom zu
importieren aus Frankreich der zu einem
gut Teil aus Atomkraft stammt
durch den aufwuchs erneuerbaren Energien
seit über 10 Jahren sind wir netto Strom
Exporteur nach Frankreich insofern hilft
sich untereinander aber wir produzieren
nicht nur Krisensituationen mehr Strom
für Frankreich als Frankreich für uns
okay ist die Zukunft und die Gegenwart
hohe Matzen so glorreich wie Jürgen
Trittin sie gerade beschreibt sie kennen
das sozusagen aus der ökonomischen
Perspektive als ehemaliger Unternehmer
als jemand der da wirklich was bewegt
hat und jetzt sind sie zuständig für
genau dieses Thema
schleswig-Holstein ist das alles so
grandios wie wir das jetzt gerade hier
beschreiben oder haben in Wahrheit immer
noch ein Problem ich habe immer gedacht
Marktwirtschaft hat was mit Angebot und
Nachfrage zu tun und wenn ich mit den
aktuellen Strompreis angucke würde ich
sagen wir haben doch die offenkundig an
angebotsprobleme sonst würden wir nicht
diese Preise bezahlen oder sich da
irgendwas falsch naja das man kann das
ja ein bisschen differenziert schauen
erstens hörte geben dass wir ein
nord-süd-problem haben ich würde ja
sagen wir haben ein südproblem statt
wir haben einen nordlösung und darauf
sollten wir glaube ich setzen wir haben
165% erneuerbare Energien zwei terrabatt
zu viel Strom
ich glaube man könnte auch sagen wir
haben zu wenig Ansiedlung das kann man
so oder so sehen was ich aber als großes
Problem sehe ist wir sind quasi
Klassenprimus und zahlen dafür aber die
höchsten Strompreise in Süddeutschland
wiederum haben wir nicht unbedingt den
Klassenprimus und sie haben deutlich
niedrigere Preise das ist ein spricht im
nett aber man will in eine Schulklasse
gehen und würde sagen so alle Schüler
die eine eins haben die kriegt Zitronen
und alle die die eine fünf haben ihr
kriegt Schokolade dann müssen wir uns
mal kurz überlegen was passiert denn in
dieser Schule Klasse ist es davon
auszugehen dass nicht jeder eine Zitrone
haben will und davon würde ich jetzt
einfach mal darauf aufsetzen und sagen
wir müssen doch die Menschen die dort
leben wo Energie entsteht damit auch
belohnen das heißt wir brauchen
Energiepreise wohnen also ich muss eine
Verständnis dafür bekommen dass wenn in
Meinberg jad ein Windkraftanlage steht
dann habe ich auch ein besseren Preis
habe ich was davon genau und dann würde
ich ja auch Ansiedlungen ermöglichen und
dann würde ich auch den Strom dort wo
entsteht verbrauchen das ist ein
bisschen das Prinzip dort und der Fisch
gefangen wird wird auch Essen und nicht
irgendwohin transportiert und wenn würde
ich ihn zumindest gerne veredeln und
dann den schönen Filet in Süddeutschland
bringen ist überhaupt kein Problem aber
teurer verkaufen darauf
selbstverständlich nicht anders weil ich
glaube gerade wenn man als Bürger in
Schleswig-Holstein unterwegs ist und man
schaut auf abgestellte Windkraftanlagen
und dann würde man schon sagen die
Diskussionen die hier im geführt wurde
ist ein bisschen von gestern und wir
sollten ein bisschen mehr in Richtung
morgen schauen wie bekommen wir das denn
hin dass wir mehr erneuerbare Energien
haben doch in dem der preiswerte der
Windkraft Energie ist so preiswert aber
wird so teuer bei uns bezahlt das kann
ich weder die Menschen die dort leben
erklären und auch nicht die Wirtschaft
und ich will natürlich Ansiedlung und
bei mir haben und deswegen werde ich
ganz stark für für Preise und Politik
das würde dazu führen dass man den
Regionen indem man bisher wenig
erneuerbaren Energien sie stärker dafür
einsetzen
wie kriegen wir das hin mit dem
günstigeren Preisen ist das auf Dauer zu
halten dass wir diesen einheitlichen
deutschen Strommarkt haben oder werden
wir irgendwann sozusagen eine Nord haben
in der es deutlich günstiger ist bei
Herrn hohe Matzen zu Hause und dann bei
Markus Söder zu Hause ein bisschen teuer
so verstanden dass wenn das so wäre es
einen starken ökonomischen Stimulus gäbe
in Bayern ebenfalls das zu tun und den
Stillstand beim Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
zu überwinden er will ja nicht Herr
Matzen will ja nicht die Bayern
bestrafen der ist ja kein Anti Bayer
sondern er sucht sozusagen
die Ausbau Blockade durchbrochen wird
und mir dahin kommt wir müssen uns doch
klar machen wir wollen 2030 80 % und so
Sturms erneuerbar haben es sind aber
nicht 80% von den heutigen 100%. das ist
sehr sehr viel mehr
gerade weil wir wenn wir Mobilität Wärme
so wenn wir Wasserstoff erzeugen wollen
all das brauchen wir erneuerbaren Strom
und dann müssen wir mehr tun und
deswegen finde ich die Idee den Bayern
ein kleinen Schubs zu geben sich da zu
bewegen viel zielführender als die
förderalisierung des Atomrechts
das ganze ist ja kein Streit Nord gegen
Süd- und Süd gegen Nord und so weiter
und ist ja auch alles wirklich nicht
trivial bis noch mal wirklich auf den
auf die große ebene sozusagen heben in
der EU sind gerade 110 Atomreaktoren am
Werk 110 im Betrieb in 13 EU-Staaten
liefern ein Viertel des gesamten Stroms
in der Union Polen die Slowakei planen
neue AKW in Finnland ist gerade ein
wahnsinniger Atomreaktor ans Netz
gegangen oder fertig geworden
1.600 Megawatt die finnischen grünen
finden das super also was wissen wir ich
werde jetzt fast gesagt mal wieder
besser als alle anderen um uns herum nee
wenn sie sich mal in der Welt umschauen
und wenn Sie feststellen dass ich glaube
89,90 muss das gewesen sein weil die
höchste Zahl von Atomreaktoren in der
Welt am Netz seitdem geht die runter
gerade 47 neue in Europa in Europa
der finnische Reaktor
Verdreifachung der Kosten mehr als
Verdoppelung der Bauzeit daran ist
beinahe die Ariva pleite gegangen und
musste vom Staat im französischen Stadt
gerettet werden in Frankreich wo man
wenn man die Substanz der AKWs ersetzen
wollte heute zehn im Bau sein müssten
ist man dabei gerade einfältig zu
stellen mit den gleichen Problemen die
der finnische halt die finden haben
einen weiteren Reaktor den sie im Bau
haben und nicht mehr betrieben weil man
festgestellt hat dass man sich dann von
Ross Atom also von Russland abhängig
machen würde das ist das Problem was
ganz Osteuropa hat warum gibt es noch
kein uranimport Stopp aus Russland weil
dann in Ungarn in der Slowakei in
Rumänien die Lichter ausgehen das heißt
wir haben dort ein ernstes Problem mit
der Versorgungssicherheit und der
Unabhängigkeit und wenn sie es auch noch
mal auf die globale Ebene sehen und
sehen wie sich die Trends entwickeln
global an Primärenergiebedarf der Welt
hat die Atomenergie keine fünf Prozent
und deswegen ist in dem ein Jahr wo 250
Gigawatt erneuerbare Kapazität neu ans
Netz gegangen ist weil wir sie in
Deutschland mit dem EEG so billig
gemacht haben 0,4
0,4 gegen 250 reine also wo ist da der
deutsche sonder wie ich habe eher den
Eindruck dass in anderen Ländern die
Frage einer nicht wettbewerbsfähigen
Energieform hochgehalten wird in Form
von Ankündigungen wenn es ans konkrete
bauen und investieren geht findet das
aber in der Realität nicht statt
als warum denken und sehen das die
Chinesen so anders die bauen gerade 47
neue AKW 47 sind gigantische Zahl ich
glaube es sind sogar mehr ich glaube
also im Moment sind wir bei 50 AKWs in
China von den 80 Prozent in den letzten
zehn Jahren gebaut worden also ich war
dort als Fukushima passiert ist da hat
China genauso wie wir auch moderatorium
gemacht und eine Denkpause eingelegt und
dann aber sehr schnell mit diesem
gewaltigen Energiehunger die die einfach
haben
ja und der zum Teil natürlich von uns
auch mit verursacht wurde weil China war
die Fabrik der Welt das heißt viele der
CO2-Emissionen vieles auch der
Energieproduktion in China war ja
letztlich unsere ja die wir da
ausgelagert haben und von diesen 50
wollen sie auf 150 kommen in den
nächsten 15 Jahren glaube ich also und
das ist und ich habe gerade letzte Woche
nicht in Ruhe Anmeldung gelesen also das
ist die chinesische Nachrichtenagentur
Propaganda Agentur natürlich
die gejubelt hat das war eine
jubelnachricht gesagt hat China hat die
sicherste die sichersten Atomreaktoren
der Welt weil nichts bekannt ist von
irgendwelchen Atomunfällen und leaks und
so und ist das ist natürlich genau das
Problem ja also ich bin auch ein Kind
von mir würde das erfahren bin oder was
passieren würde eben das erfahren wir
wahrscheinlich nicht ich kann mich
erinnern als ich dort war haben wir
einmal von einem Lied erfahren weil in
Hongkong das damals noch viel mehr
Unabhängigkeit genossen als es ist das
heute tut in Hongkong plötzlich erhöhte
Radioaktivität gemessen wurde die von
einem AKW in guango in der
Nachbarprovinz von Hongkong aus ausging
aber wir würden es natürlich nicht
erfahren weil die Zensur fast
wasserdicht ist weil es keine
unabhängigen Medien gibt keine
unabhängigen Gerichte und deswegen ja
wir würden uns mitkriegen das ist ja das
Thema also es ist uns ja nicht egal oder
kann uns nicht egal sein ob in China 50
neue AKW gebaut werden also der Fallout
würde uns irgendwann
dank ungünstiger Winde so oder so
treffen ja wir sind zwar weit weg aber
letztlich ich meine wie wir dann bei
Fukushima gesehen haben und davor ich
bin Kind von tschernoby auch also
shit happens ja und wenn ähm wenn das
mal passiert irgendwie bei einer
Technologie die dann so unbeherrschbar
wird wenn was schief geht dann haben wir
ein großes Problem und wer das Problem
wird umso größer wenn das in einem Staat
passiert der eben wie wir auch beim
Ausbruch von Corona gesehen habe erst
mal wo der erste Reflex ist verschweigen
vertuschen stillen
nochmal zurück zu uns und nochmal zur
Frage was das für uns als
Volkswirtschaft bedeutet ich weiß dass
das viele Leute und hat wie groß ist
ihre Sorge eigentlich damals jemand der
aus der Wirtschaft kommt
das irgendwann diese Energiewende der
gigantische Strombedarf der Zukunft die
Tatsache dass wir ein ganzes Land eine
ganze Gesellschaft elektrifizieren und
auch wenn wir hingehen und sagen auch
den Wärmebereich jetzt kommen uns ja
gleich mal anschauen wieder die Zahlen
konkret aussehen da sind wir nämlich
mitnichten so gute wenn manchmal den
Anschein erwecken sie mir sogar ziemlich
schlecht
Wärmepumpen bedeutet übersetzt nichts
anderes als Heizen mit Strom es ist
nichts anderes das heißt wie groß ist
ihre Sorge dass wir irgendwann
tatsächlich nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig
sind muss ich mal anschauen wir zahlen
deutsche Endverbraucher Zahlen glaube
ich was haben wir 40 sind im Moment
ungefähr mal mehr mal weniger 37 ja so
Norweger Zahlen vier
Schweden Zahlen glaube ich 20 24 25 also
in der Tat gibt es Franken wenn ich
unterwegs bin und mit dem Betrieben
spreche die große Sorgen haben sei es
zum Beispiel wer Chemiebranche die sehr
Energie intensiv ist und die wo wirklich
die Unterschiede zwischen verschiedenen
Produkte im Centbereich liegen die haben
natürlich dann Wettbewerbsnachteile die
von wirklich ja große Bedeutung sind und
die dazu führen dass man Deutschland den
Rücken kehrt und darüber müssen wir uns
natürlich im Klaren sein ich habe auch
ansiedlungsgespräche das heißt zum
Beispiel ein Batterie Fabrik die auch
sehr viele
brauchen sehr viel Energie und sie sind
natürlich darauf angewiesen dass ich
auch ein verlässlichen Strompreis über
Jahre den sicherstellen kann und
deswegen können sie das im Moment kann
ich das natürlich nicht dann bin ich bei
Argument von eben dann müssen wir es
natürlich so hinbekommen dass der sehr
preiswerte offshore Windstrom Preis auch
weitergeleitet sehr gute
Schleswig-Holstein
sehr sehr preiswert möglich wäre
aber wenn ich die netzausbauten deswegen
weil ich sehr vorbildliche unterwegs bin
mitbezahlen muss dann ist das ein
Problem für ansiedlungsgespräch ist ein
Problem für unsere Wirtschaft insgesamt
und ich glaube vor nicht mal ein halbes
Jahr gab es in Deutschland sehr große
Diskussionen darüber ob wir überhaupt
Energiesicherheit haben richtig und da
muss man sich natürlich fragen wenn man
bereit ist 4 5 Milliarden Euro
Investitionen in ein Land zu machen wo
man diskutiert ob man überhaupt Energie
hat ich glaube das ist schon etwas
schwierig und deswegen gilt es in erster
Linie da bleibe ich nochmals dabei wir
müssen unabhängiger werden wir müssen
die Erneuerbaren deutlich stärker
ausbauen und da gilt es einfach dass wir
jetzt so ein Hauch Mentalität auch
hinbekommen angesprochen war jetzt auch
ein bisschen die Mentalität anderer in
Dänemark hat man schon in den 70er
Jahren
gerade so Angst macht dieses Gefühl ist
es kommt so ein neues Wort auf Deutsch
Deutschland Tempo ich weiß gar nicht ob
das ein gutes Wort ist sondern
möchte ich allerdings anmerken wenn wir
kleinen Schritt langsamer werden dann
sind wir ein Dias Show also da wir
können überhaupt nicht von Deutschland
Tempo reden die Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit ja also da wie gesagt da
da müssen wir uns dann mal andere Länder
anschauen wenn wir über das Wort
Geschwindigkeit sprechen das ist einen
sind wir unfassbar langsam und lassen
uns Zeit beim anderen wollen wir es dann
quasi mit der Brechstange und fast über
Nacht ja beim Thema Energie Thema Heizen
ja absolut aber bei manchen dieser
Themen ich glaube der Herr Thomas stieg
ist ja jetzt auch nicht über Nacht
passiert sondern auch schon sehr lange
bei anderen Themen sind wir schon sehr
lange unterwegs und wir werden Problem
ist uns sehr sehr eingefallen und das
stimmt und in der Tat ist das so wie
gesagt in den 70er Jahren hat man in
Dänemark gemerkt aufgrund der erste
Ölkrise wir müssen jetzt ein anderes
Wärmesystem für Dänemark finden wir
müssen auf grüne Industrien setzen und
das ist ja genau wie euch muss es ja
immer wieder auch sagen da ich ja von
Schleswig-Holstein komme wir wollen ein
grünes Industrieland werden das bedeutet
natürlich auch dass wir wirklich massiv
dort auch ansetzen müssen ja und das
wird problematisch wenn wir alles mit
Strom machen wollen Mobilität Wärme und
natürlich alles andere auch aber das
bedeutet auch dass wir da massiv besser
werden Frau tut jetzt noch mal wirklich
die nackten Zahlen also gibt dann immer
so diese diese eine Zahl die mal
rumgeistert wir sind ja schon bei 40%
erneuerbare und da ist sozusagen den
Strom genau gut dass sie sagen
aber in der Öffentlichkeit entsteht dann
häufig so der Eindruck das läuft schon
die Hälfte deswegen haben wir quasi
geschafft immer mal genau rechnet stellt
man fest wir sind noch nicht mal bei 20%
ich trag das mal ganz kurz vor wir haben
beim Strom haben wir 40% erneuerbare bei
Wärme nur 16 und beim Verkehr sind wir
faktisch blank sind wir bei 7 Prozent
das heißt es ist eine gigantische
Wegstrecke die noch vor uns liegt
glauben Sie daran dass das gelingt mit
ein paar weiteren Windrädern und ein
bisschen Photovoltaikanlagen ich sag's
vorweg ich glaube es nicht ja also ich
wollte noch mal darauf zurückkommen es
ist ja ein Unterschied ob man
deutschlandtempo jetzt sagt um Dinge
auch mal zu ermöglichen also das auch
mal die Regierung aus dem quarkkopf
sagte ja auch ein schöner Satz vom Reden
ins doing ja das ist nicht so schön aber
man sagt das jetzt wirklich so genau
also das ist ja das eine dass man
endlich mal nicht so ein Mini Kompromiss
zehn Jahre braucht sondern dass man
Dinge ermöglicht und Regeln schafft die
auch praktikabel und pragmatisch sind
ich würde sagen beim Ausbau der erneuer
fahren da muss ich jetzt mal als
Wirtschaftsministerium loben hat es
eigentlich jetzt inzwischen ganz gute
Regeln geschaffen wie kann man jetzt als
Basis nehmen dass der Ausbau auch
tatsächlich stattfindet ich glaube aber
was jetzt diesen Ausbau angeht da ist
diese Haltung und das mindset in den um
jetzt wieder mal deutsch zu sprechen in
den Behörden und bei den Menschen die es
umsetzen müssen vielleicht noch nicht so
dass man so ins gelingen verliebt ist
und das jetzt richtig durchbringen will
und das ist noch so ein Punkt und dann
kommen halt so andere Probleme dazu die
ganz neu sind die man jetzt aber auch
nicht von nachlassen kann wo kriegen wir
eigentlich den ganzen das ganze Material
her um die diese ganzen Stromnetze und
diese ganzen Energieanlagen zu schaffen
zu bauen das ist inzwischen ganz teuer
geworden
dann können wir auch nicht mehr so viel
verbauen was von dort kommt und wenn man
dann auch noch die Finanzierung beachten
Zinsen gehen nach oben das ist macht die
Sache unglaublich teurer also da haben
wir auch einen Flaschenhals der trotzdem
vielleicht der Haltung die sich ändert
und der Regeln die besser geworden sind
das alles sehr mühsam und sehr schwer
weitermachen sie sagen billiger wird
Strom in Zukunft auf jeden Fall nicht
er hätte ihn stimmt dem faktisch zu sagt
dass
ich hier habe ich gelesen das für die
privaten Haushalte die Gaspreise gerade
um 32 % nach oben gehen also das muss
man ja auch mal sehen was ist sozusagen
der Preis des festhalten
das jetzt wieder der Vergleichspunkt
am Ende am Ende müssen Sie wenn Sie
etwas investieren noch abwägen was ist
langfristig das preisgünstiger der
preisgünstigereffekt und wir haben mit
der russischen Invasion in der Ukraine
gelernt das ist in den fossilen Märkten
beachtliche Preisrisiken gibt ich
schaffe das mal nur so ja ist richtig
und wenn man wenn man dann gemeinsam
sagt wir wollen daraus und dann auch
noch feststellt dass wir im Stromsektor
in der Industrie eigentlich nicht so
schlecht sind das muss man sagen die
Industrie in Deutschland hat Klimaschutz
betrieben aber im Verkehrssektor und
beim Heizen sind wir schlecht richtig
schlecht und da muss man doch Wege
finden wie man aus der Abhängigkeit von
fossilen rauskommt wie man weniger CO2
macht und wie man das halbwegs sozusagen
belastbar und investiert macht und dazu
gehört immer eine Betrachtung auch was
die Entwicklung ist auf dem fossilen
Sektor nicht so der Foss Sektor und mein
Punkt ist auch nicht dass es den Krieg
in der Ukraine gibt und das
erdgas-taucher geworden ist aber mein
Punkt ist können wir es uns als
viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt
ernsthaft leisten so einen Satz so
lässig auszusprechen zu sagen Strom wird
in Zukunft jedenfalls nicht billiger
sondern wird teurer mit der Perspektive
dass wir ein ganzes Land eine ganze
Gesellschaft in den nächsten 10 15
Jahren immer weiter elektrifizieren
wollen ich habe die Zahlen gerade
vorgetragen wie weit das noch geht also
wenn wir gerade mal 20 Prozent des Weges
geschafft haben dann frage ich mich wie
man in dieser Situation einfach
entspannt drei AKW abschreiben
am Rande wir reden bei den Strompreisen
zur Zeit darüber dass dort Sachen drin
stecken die insbesondere Investitionen
in die Infrastruktur beinhalten die
Stromerzeugungskosten
Recht die sind massiv gesunken durch den
Einsatz der hier abgebildeten Windräder
es gibt keine Form der Stromerzeugung
die so billig ist wie Wind und Sonne da
kann nichts mithalten das Problem ist
für uns wir müssen unsere gesamte
Energieversorgung unsere Netze all
dieses umbauen so diese
Infrastrukturkosten werden zurzeit auf
die Stromkosten umgelegt wird wenn sie
nur auf die produzierte Kilowattstunde
gucken so war der Strom noch nie so
billig und deswegen ist er der Grund
warum die Unternehmen in
Schleswig-Holstein bei ihm Anfragen
können wir nicht direkt Anschluss an
Windpark haben und das Zeug selber
verbrauchen und nur das Überschuss geben
wir als Netz weil dann kriegen wir die
Kilowattstunde für drei vier Cent